uh
hello for those of you who are just
getting here
you already made the first mistake and i
can't believe you
the fact that you're here and not
listening to distractible
is a disgrace and unforgivable
i see you chatting i see you typing with
your words
when you should be typing with your ears
alone
there is an opportunity a grand
opportunity that only comes once in a
lifetime and you're squandering it by
being here and not being distracted by
distractible
and yet you come here you come here
instead of going to the link in the
description below and clicking it to go
to distractible and find it wherever you
listen to podcast the best either apple
podcast or spotify
you're here and not there
no i can't believe you
i can't believe you the fact that you
are not going there right now and
downloading
distractible the podcast that
bob wade and i slaved over
we sweated to the bone
we worked our fingers to nubs for you
you think it was easy no you think it
was
you think it was easy you think it was
easy
you think we didn't hone our craft for
years
with three peens in the pods for you to
come here and assume that it was
easy putting this wonderful podcast
together for you
no yes whatever the answer is
you're wrong you know why because you're
here listening to me
instead of going to the link in the
description below and clicking it so
that you can listen to distractable on
whatever device you prefer to listen to
i can barely believe you i see you now
those of you saying that you already did
do you think you're exempt from the
rules do you think you're exempt
from your punishment no i am
disappointed
because if you're focused on me right
now you're not properly distracted
and if you're not properly distracted
then you didn't listen closely enough
oh ye little distractions
i need you right now to go into the link
in the description below
and click it right now so that you can
be taken
over to distractible the podcast
where we bob wade and i talk about
hair hair growth hair removal all types
of different hair
if you like the energy of three peens in
a pod in the podcast we did every
tuesday on twitch almost every tuesday
then you're gonna love this one we have
distilled
all of the chaotic energy that we know
and love and you know
and love and you know that we know and
you love into a podcast that you can
truly enjoy
the fact that you're still here is just
devastating to me it's devastatingly
disappointing it's devastatingly
misunderstandable i can't believe it
i can't believe you focused bastards
think that you don't need to be
distracted
what are you trying to do homework are
you trying to study
are you trying to get your grades up is
it exam time
that's not what tonight is for
no it is time to listen and if you've
already listened
it's time to listen again you need to go
down into the description below and
right
now immediately click that link and go
check out distractable it's a wonderful
name for a podcast that really
captures everything that we are and that
we've done
throughout the entirety of our careers
on the internet
we just let our minds wander it's the
true essence of adhd distilled into a
single podcast that allows you to get a
glimpse into our minds
and the inner imaginations of our minds
is a treasure trove of beautiful stories
and definitely rigid rules that
absolutely make sense
once and for all don't go away go away
go somewhere other than where you are
right now listen to me
and also if you are listening to me you
are not listening to
me because you didn't click on the link
in the description below if you're
listening to me unless you're listening
to me on the distractible podcast where
i'm speaking there
but not here that's not live this is
live
maybe someday we will do a live
distractible but that is not this moment
right here
right in this moment where you and i are
making eye contact
right now i see you there i see
all of you i see you greg i see you
stacy i see you samantha
i see all of you alex oh yes
i know what you're doing and it's not
nearly enough procrastination
no no no this
this is a distraction this
you think this is the distraction you
have no idea
what the distraction is you have no idea
the things i am capable of distracting
you from
all of your worries all of your concerns
all of the things that you need to get
done your deadlines
they can wait i am officially saying me
markiplier giving you my grand authority
to skip
out on any responsibilities that you
ever had and be distracted right now
in this moment because together
we are going to show the world just how
distracted we can be
by going into the description and
clicking on the link to the distractible
podcast
oh yes it's true all of your dreams come
true
through the link in the description
below everything you've ever loved and
wanted is waiting for you on the other
side of that link
didn't you know didn't you hear the good
news
but don't leave not yet you're not
allowed to leave because i'm still
lecturing you that was a trick you
should have left immediately
you shouldn't even be here right now why
are you still listening to me if you're
still listening to me
you're not following the rules and the
rules are that there are no rules except
the rules that we impose in the podcast
of distractable where we have some sort
of rule set for the competition that we
have
which is very thoroughly judged and
properly executed so that everything
matters which it does and it doesn't
you paying attention obviously but you
shouldn't be
because this is about distractible the
link in the description below will take
you on a journey to take you to places
that you never even imagined that your
brain could go
you think six degrees of separation
works for everybody in the world
to know each other what about six
degrees of separation from
a herm statue to hair removal
not so easy now is it look into my eyes
i want you to look deep into my eyes
right now stop doing whatever it is
you're doing
don't get distracted now unless you're
clicking on the link in the description
below and then you can absolutely get
distracted
let's try this again look into my eyes
see the truth lurking deep within them
see your soul reflected in the windows
to mine
and you know that you've disappointed me
because you're still here listening to
me looking into my eyes
and if you were listening to the
distractible podcast you would not be
looking into my eyes because there is no
video component to it you would know
that if you had clicked on that
link in the description below but you
didn't get away go get back
you don't deserve to be this close you
get the wide angle
you get the wide angle of shame that's
what you get can't believe you
i can't even fathom you right now and i
can fathom a lot
oh i can fathom a lot but i can't fathom
you right now
i absolutely cannot i'm gonna level with
you
i'm gonna be honest with you here i'm
gonna this this is about the most real
i'm gonna get with you guys
enough of the bit you know enough of the
jokes you know enough of that everything
about
you know the whole ha ha yeah you know
there's a link in the description you
know there absolutely is but let me be
real with you i'm going to tell you
about as real as it's going to get
i don't often get this real with you
guys i i try to keep it all in and i try
to make sure that people don't
see the the truth inside but like since
you're here right now i just want to be
fully open and honest with you guys i
want to
absolutely connect with you on a deeper
level because that's important to me
that's very important to me
uh the link is broken
no don't say that
don't say that to me
you crashed away you
you douchebag you broke it you
broke it what is wrong with you you
broke it you
listen listen i don't know why you
thought that you could actually listen
to me
and click the link in the description
below number one how dare you number two
how dare you
how absolute dare you i was about to be
honest
and i was about to level with you i was
about to reveal you the truth of my soul
you get back into the zoom out of shame
the wide angle of shame is all you
deserve now i gotta fix what you broke
you did this it's all your fault
i can't i i just you know you think you
can trust someone and absolutely you
cannot
you just can't trust anybody anymore and
don't you
leave don't you leave you sit right
there
you listen to me and you listen good
you'll sit there and i'm gonna fix your
mistake
i can't believe this you think you can
just break a link like this you think
you can
you sit right there you sit right there
and you think about what you did
you think about what you did oh i know
you could go and search for it on
apple podcasts or spotify but no you had
to break
the thing that i gave to you i
gave you that i gave you that
and i trusted you i
trusted you and
look at where that got me look at where
that
trust got me i thought i could trust you
but
turns out the only thing i could trust
you with
was breaking my heart
i trust you with crushing my soul
and you know i'm not i'm not like a
i know i'm not like a perfect person i i
know that i
i know but you know i try i try really
hard
and you know i just like bob wade and i
we tried really hard to make this
podcast for you and it's
make it something that you could listen
to
i guess you know i guess that trust just
i guess it doesn't go both ways
but you can make it up to me i just
fixed the link down in the description
below you have to refresh right now
refresh immediately refresh your browser
or whatever you're looking at this on
and you can see in the description below
brand new links now when you refresh you
come right back here and i'm about to
give you some of the business
and when i give you the business you're
gonna take the business okay
but don't go away and click on links
unless you do which is the correct
answer
because you shouldn't even be here you
absolutely should not be here
but refresh get back here
okay good glad we settled that
finally people started listening all
right
are you back are you back here because i
i really do want to level with you guys
i want to i want to level
okay i i refresh i put new links in
there it should all be fine
if it's not fine i highly doubt that
you're able to break the full
website of apple podcasts because if you
did that
that you can't do that
that is actually not possible so also
spotify
i highly doubt that you did any of that
so your ambitions may be large
but my doubt is larger now listen to me
and listen good are you listening you're
not listening if you're not looking at
me and if you're not looking at me
you're not listening to me
there are now three links in the
description there's three and
all of them you need to listen to me too
okay you need to absolutely listen to me
because i'm i'm gonna be honest with you
guys
like
i'm gonna
i'm gonna level with you
i'm gonna tell you things that you know
i don't tell a lot of people
i'm gonna like i'm gonna reveal part of
who i am to you that pretty much no one
gets to see
it's kind of things that i think about a
lot and um
you know they they tie into who i am as
a person and
and you know you're kind of the only
people that i trust right now
and
i uh
anyway i just think that i can trust you
guys with what i'm about to say
and when i say it to you guys when i say
this thing to you guys that i
like understand that it's really coming
from my soul and my heart
and um that it's not easy for me to talk
about these things with you guys it's
not easy for me to
open up in this way you know haven't
done it in a while i guess you know i
used to do it more but
you know now that i'm going to open up
with you guys
now in here and here and now and in this
moment together when i open up to you
guys
just understand it's because i trust you
you know
and i think you should look at that with
some respect when i trust you with this
thing that i'm about to tell you this
big secret inside my soul and the
the the sorrow that i carry with me you
know
and i hope you're looking at me directly
because you should be paying attention
very closely to what i'm saying
and when i tell you these things that
i'm going to tell you and the the
importance that they
hold for me um and kind of like the it's
the kind of thing
that i i i stay up late thinking about
just because it's so important to me
what i'm about to say to you
the things that i stay up late thinking
about is um
it's just like man
it's it's kind of the core of who i am
and also like some
pretty uh pretty heavy secrets that i
got
you know a lot of secrets i have many
secrets and i'm gonna tell you a secret
i will i will tell you a secret i'll
tell you the deepest secret i have
and when i tell you this secret
wow when i tell you this secret it's
really going to be something special but
it's very serious
that's uh it's very heavy this secret
it's like a burden you know it's like a
burden that i bear
everyone would want to know the secret
that i'm about to tell you
and i man you know it's weird even
thinking about saying this secret to you
guys because i very rarely tell the
secret to anybody that i've ever known
you know some of the closest friends
that i have you know bob and wade the
person the people that i made the
distractible podcast with
an equal part you know the people that i
would trust more than pretty much
anybody like
i would would i tell them this secret i
ask myself that it's really like heavy
to even think about debating talking
about such a heavy secret and
yeah you know when i tell you this
secret that i know you want to hear
this deep connected secret that is a
part of who i am and who you will be
once i tell you the secret is just like
it's really something special all right
so i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you the
secret i'm gonna tell you the secret now
i'm gonna tell you the secret now
i'm gonna tell you the secret here we go
that's kind of funny but also i'm
nervous you know i'm nervous telling you
this secret i i'm nervous
whoo man it's uh it's gonna be tough
talking about this secret with you guys
because the secret is really secretive
something that i keep secret deep in my
soul i don't record this by the way
don't nobody better be recording this
okay no one better be recording this
this is just between you and me
okay in this moment we are connected
through a bridge across the internet
and it's just you and me it's you and me
and maybe someday i'll share with bob
and
wade maybe on the distractible podcast
which is available through the link in
the description below
uh the various links that are in the
description below and you know maybe you
should click on those
because um you know those those are
pretty cool we worked really hard on
those but
but the secret is actually uh only
tangentially related to that only
tangentially related to that secret
um but yeah so uh here we go you know
here we here we go i'm gonna i'm gonna
tell you this i'm gonna
tell you the secret i wanna tell you a
secret
ah man here we go
we made a podcast what the hell are you
doing you get the zoom out of shame the
secret is that i know that you have not
listened
to the distractible podcast what the
hell you know how much that makes me sad
you know how much i stay up sleep not
doing you know how much i i
i don't how could you do this to me
how could you do this to me you know
it's like a betrayal right there's a
link
in the description below there are three
links in the description below
if you've refreshed which i don't even
know that you did i don't even know if
you did that
but if you've refreshed and you see the
three links down there you just pick
whichever one's your favorite
they all pretty much work unless they
don't and then you broke it and it's
your fault
that's the secret what have you done the
secret is
what the hell that's the secret okay
really
i mean there's just these big beautiful
links huge flappy links
down in the description below and they
are waiting
for you they are waiting for you to
click on them and you're not
clicking on them you're not listening to
the distractible podcast
what do you even do with your life what
are you even doing with your life
because i don't know at this point bring
back that weird ambiance
i don't even know at this point you know
what i mean i don't even know i don't
even understand
i don't even understand but let me try
to understand this okay
all right okay steve uh-huh okay
abigail okay all right all right
katie you want to listen to me this time
you want to listen to me
zoe hmm you want to listen
terence you going to pay attention to me
this time well you shouldn't be
because what's the lesson that we
learned in this entire thing
you shouldn't even be here you're not
supposed to be here you
are supposed to be clicking in the link
in the description below and
be away from this place listening to
distractible
because if you're not then bob wait i'm
gonna i'm gonna like
i'm gonna tell on you to bob and wade
they are going to be so mad at you they
are going to be
so mad at you there are still way too
many people here
for them to even understand that you
gave it an effort
to go listen to distractible which
clearly you have not
so why are you not i want to hear your
explanation why
right now you know what right now i'm
actually opening up the phones so that
you can tell me
what the hell that's the that's the
question of the day what the hell
you know what you write in the comments
what the hell
whatever your answer is to that i want
to know because what the hell
you know honestly just plain old what
the hell hmm
that's kind of what i want to know right
now what the hell there's a perfectly
good podcast waiting for you down in the
description below
i'm not gonna come because i am calm
this is me calm you want to see me angry
oh
you don't want to see me angry this is
calm you're getting calm
and to be perfectly honest calm is all
you deserve
because distractible what fun we have
there
what joyous moments we share we share
with you
and a wonderful podcast that we have
carefully crafted for you
what joys we have there that truly
is where you belong in the land of milk
and honey
whatever the hell that means but i'm
gonna tell bob and wait
i'm gonna tell them on you i'm gonna
tell you on them i'm gonna tell you on
them to you
and them they're gonna know
and when they do know oh man
it's gonna be rough that's gonna be real
rough because they're not as nice as i
am they're not as nice as i am i don't
know if you've known this about them but
they are not as nice as them
look at me in my eyes
look how nice i am right i'm forgiving
i'm forgiving of you guys you
haven't listened to the podcast and i am
somehow in my
bountiful forgiveness forgiving you for
that that is like the
worst worst transgression you could
possibly do to me
like anime betrayal top ten
top five and yet here i am
ready to be heard again i put three
links in the description below
you've probably heard me already say
that there are three links in the
description below
and yet you have done nothing
who here has been here since the very
beginning of this live stream
who here has been here for about 20
minutes
listening to me and not doing anything
about it
that is just absurd that's nonsensical
that is absolutely nonsensical
you know what this isn't even enough for
me to yell at you
just through youtube i need to yell at
you on
every platform that i have which is why
i'm about to go live
on instagram as well because i'm going
to continue to yell at you
there just you wait you're about to get
the business
just you wait oh i'm going to give you
the biz
hey hi hi
instagram it's me it's markiplier
it's your buddy i just wanted to pop in
again and say
i really appreciate you you are
fantastic
you are so much better than pretty much
every other live streaming platform that
i've seen around here
and i just want to say you're fantastic
you're great
you're gonna go far i really believe in
you and hey
i also wanted to mention there's a
podcast that me
bob and wade made it's called
distractible it's available on apple
podcast and it's available on spotify
and if you want to listen to it i would
really appreciate that and that would be
super cool if you
to do that so seriously thank you
thank you for being such a good fan
thank you for being here with me
thank you for just really giving me all
the best feelings
and vibes and all the crazy creations
that you guys make for me
really are stellar you're
so great you know you're really great
i love you i love you guys i love you so
much
you're so special to me so distractible
podcast
apple podcast spotify made by bob wade
and i
you're really going to love it and hey
i'd really appreciate if you checked it
out because i think it's really funny
and i think that you guys are going to
enjoy it
and i wanted to give something back to
you because you give so much to me
okay cool all right i'm going to get out
of here remember
distractible apple podcast spotify
go check it out but make sure you get
your homework done first you know
all right okay cool you have a good one
you have a good one now you have a good
one you have a good one now
what the hell are you still doing here
hey douche nozzle
what are you doing here there's a link
in the description ah this is every time
with you guys every freaking time with
you guys
i come back and suddenly oh i'm still
looking at his
face and no i tell you to do one thing
and you never do it
what what's your excuse this time
oh i can't wait to read what the excuses
are
oh look at that excuses oh look at these
excuses so
many excuses oh boy we don't have any
reason
not to look at the links in the
description it's just a link
it's it's a link click on it tap on it
with your finger use your mouse and
click
on it i couldn't have made it easier i
couldn't have spelled it out any easier
and yet
here you are not doing the thing that
i'm asking you to do
why what the hell do i got to do to
justify this to you
that it's a good idea to listen to this
podcast but no every time
it's gotta be a battle with you it's
gotta be a battle
it's a fight it's a goddamn fight it's a
brawl
it's a brawl but i'll get through your
thick skull one day
link in the description and you just
gotta
click on it i literally couldn't have
made it
any easier for you
do people need like a step-by-step guide
i'll give a step-by-step guide i'll give
a step-by-step guide okay
all right let's remove the whole link
thing because many of you may not be
able to comprehend you'll just look down
you'll see a bunch of
letters and numbers and you'll be like i
don't know what that is
so let's just imagine this okay you know
the google right you know the google
okay you type google or you don't even
need to type google sometimes but let's
assume that you type the google
in the google okay you go to google
and you type in let's say for example
you wanted to listen to you gotta pick
i'm sorry it's two choices you have to
pick okay one in the other one's apple
podcast
one is spotify okay is this two can you
do two can you
let's reduce to one let's not deal with
two right now
let's start with one and we'll go from
there okay
everyone with me if you're with me say
you're with me but also focus
okay apple podcast so what you want to
do is you want to go
to apple podcast and you there's a
search bar
okay there's a search bar it's like a
little
horizontal gray bar maybe about that
long compared to it's usually up at the
top
i don't know where it is you can find it
and you type distractible now i'm going
to spell it out it's
d-i-s-t-r-a-c-t-i-b-l-e
a lot of letters a lot of letters but
hey
you can do it oh my god and then you hit
enter which is the button on your
keyboard that says enter
now what you're going to do when you do
that is you're going to look for some
special
artwork you're going to look for some
real special artwork
and uh it's gonna be really cool and
it's
pretty fun so you get that special
artwork
and it looks like this you see this
this really neat artwork look at this
pretty cool right you like pretty
pictures right you like pretty pictures
look at this pretty picture
ooh colors it's got lots of explosions
and things like that
for you to pay attention to okay don't
get distracted
oh my god and then you look for this and
you click on this or you tap on this
and then you go to the first episode
it's only one word it's called
hair and you click on that and you
listen to us
and then magically our voices will be in
your ears and you will be able to hear
us okay
also also there's
links in the description
yeah and yeah it's free it is absolutely
free
for you to listen to okay all right
everyone following good hey
i just want to let you know that was
only for the other people not you though
you're really special i know that this
seems like
oh it's so slow and dumb but it's just
for those other guys who are a little
bit you know
little bit you know we're gonna
be perfect last but not you i know that
you
hey look at me you've done a lot for
this community
and you've done a lot for me and you're
really a great valuable part of it
and i appreciate you being here i
appreciate
the fact that you've supported me for so
long means the world to me
it really does don't tell any of the
others but you know
special what you do i'm grateful for it
and you know the link is in the
description and i know that you i don't
need to walk you
through that i don't know you got this i
understand
so just want to get a chance link it is
in the description
take a little listen okay cool now i
gotta get back to these others
so spotify all right anyway so listen
guys
i love this podcast
have i talked actually about how this
podcast
is to us and and you guys if you've ever
listened to us
on our tuesday streams we actually do
kind of like a podcast on tuesdays but
lately we've been working so hard on
this one
that uh in the best part of the tuesday
streams is just
us like just going on tangents
about random nonsense and getting topics
that get us to go to strange
places in terms of our conversations and
really that's what it's all about that
is legitimately what it's all about
that is what this podcast is all about
and
i really do honestly truly think that
you guys will enjoy it
if you've never listed a listened to a
podcast before
this one is probably a little bit
different from what you guys are used to
but if you like the dynamic of bob wade
and i
some of my oldest friends in the world
uh
like it's just this really fun
atmosphere and i think we came up with
this like
pseudo game show with like whose line is
in any way style point system
uh and it really allows us to talk about
whatever we want and go on
whatever journey we want in terms of the
stories that we're telling
and it just allows us to go to crazy
places so if you get a chance
click the link in the description below
you won't regret it
i i'm willing to bet that you will enjoy
the podcast
i just really want you guys to give it a
try and give it a solid listen
because it's something that i'm really
proud of and i'm really proud of making
and i'm really happy to be able to do
this with my friends
so if you like that kind of thing if you
like bob and wade and the videos that we
do together
this podcast is really going to be
something for you so definitely go give
it a try
now anyway what the hell are you still
doing here huh i see that there's still
over
27 000 people here and that's 27 000
more people than there should be here
uh-huh okay you understand me now
are you getting what i'm saying i know
these numbers are real big but i believe
that you can actually appreciate them
because you'd have to be some kind of a
super genius to mess with me as much as
you're messing with me
there are so many people here that
aren't listening to the podcast
when you could be listening to the
podcast right now and you're listening
to me talk and i don't understand what
that's about
that's a little weird don't you think i
keep saying that there's a podcast
through the links in the description is
it because i put too many links in there
are you getting confused it's like a
maze you go to one then the other
they're all the same
they're all the same they all go to the
same place you all go to a place you're
gonna listen to the same podcast
it's just gonna be us talking we have
new episodes every week
if you follow it you'll know when we get
new episodes up so go follow it or
subscribe to it or whatever you do to
make sure you go follow a podcast
and get the hell out of here i literally
am not gonna leave until everyone here
is gone
so you better get the hell out of here
because i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
leave
you're gonna leave you can't beat me on
this i've got nothing else to do
i left set early today and that means
that i have nothing to do
i will pass out here before i let you
beat me you're gonna listen to this
podcast
and you're not gonna be here when you
listen to it or you're listening to it
right now and then you're
just being an i'm willing to bet
that's the truth of it
i'm willing to bet that's the truth of
it i'm willing i'm willing to bet
i'm will oh i'm willing to bet oh i'm
willing to bet
i can't believe it i can't believe you
guys
you know but you know it is
it is what it is
i'm i'm just calling up some extra help
i'm just i'm just calling up some extra
help
can't believe this i have to actually
get some extra help
geez
okay
hey what's up there guys listen i'm on
the other line with
youtube don't tell them you know they
can't hear me i'm muted over there i'm
on the other line with youtube and you
guys know youtube they're a little bit
they're a little bit you know they're a
little bit you know but anyway
i'm on i'm on the other line with
youtube and i just need you guys to
really talk to these guys
because um they're not listening to me
you know they don't really have a good
listening problem where i feel like you
guys have
like a really strong listening ability
and it's something that i actually
truly appreciate and and i think that
like you guys understand me when i'm
saying something it's pretty
easy to understand what i'm saying right
whereas you know youtube
you know what i mean but listen okay so
i have this podcast
right that bob wade and i came out with
you know how we do pocket you guys know
we do podcasts because of course like we
do it on twitch like it's special
you know you guys are special and we we
do it for you guys
you guys have been enjoying it for years
now
years now and so now we have this
podcast called the distractible podcast
and you guys can listen to the distilled
essence of what makes three peens in a
pod so great don't worry youtube is
muted right now
they can't hear a word i'm saying um but
you get the distilled essence of what
distractible podcast
is in such a delightful package that you
can listen to right now so if you go
over to like distractible on apple
podcast or spotify you can check that
out
and also here here's the crazy thing
we're still not gonna we're gonna keep
doing tuesday streams that's the crazy
thing you guys get
double the content everyone else gets
like one extra content
you guys could double the content but
okay here's a favor obviously you can go
listen to the podcast and that'd be
really cool and i would really
appreciate that
but can you just like talk to these
youtube guys
like i don't know what it is about the
youtube crop but they're just a little
bit
a little bit crazy they're just a little
bit like
a little bit not so you know i i keep
telling them
that they need to like you know click
the link and they just
they just don't do it where's you guys
like oh my god you're so good
about just like you have an opportunity
in front of you it's totally free
entertainment and then you just do it
right so if you could just like put in a
good word with youtube that would be
super cool
that would be super great that would be
so cool i would really appreciate that
okay hey thanks guys you know you always
are
the special ones you know that that
really is how it goes like i would never
tell youtube this but you
you guys are like
you guys are the special ones you know
what i mean you guys are absolutely the
special ones
okay okay cool just smooches
uh remember distractible podcast it's
available on apple podcast
and spotify so go check that out but
just
you guys are the special ones you're my
favorites
okay cool you keep that in your heart
because that ain't going nowhere
just like me and here okay cool all
right i'm gonna get out of here all
right see you around
i gotta go back they're muted on the
other line i'll see you around though
i'll see you all right later
okay good they're so great they're so
green
they're so great oh
hey what's up guys how you doing you're
my favorite
you're my favorite guys you guys you are
my favorite all right listen
you listening you're listening to me
there's a link in the description
but i warn you
it's not for the faint of heart
there's a link in the description that
it's dangerous not many people have
come back from it it's consumed
people the
twisting paths and the shrouded forests
there
they're more than some people can handle
and i don't know if you're
strong enough to get through it i don't
know
and i'm scared for you there's
three links in the description there's
three
and if you choose wrong you might be
lost
to the ether
but yeah i'm telling you this because i
know that you're brave enough
and strong enough for at least some of
you to survive
but i just am warning you the links in
the description are dangerous
they hold the power that
not many can wield
so when you go down there in the
description you click on the links that
will take you to the distractible
podcast that me and my friends made
just know that once you cross that
threshold i won't be able to help you
you'll be on the on your own over there
you'll be hearing the voices of someone
that sounds a lot like me bob and wade
and that's because it is me bob and wade
but once you hear them
there's no guarantee that that's
actually us
except for the guarantee that i'm saying
right now that that is actually us but
just be careful
just be careful never know what lurks
on the other side
anywho zooming in now hey what's up guys
okay this has all been a big bit
right it's all just been a joke i didn't
mean a word that i said
obviously youtube is my favorite
platform of all the platforms
and the people that come here and see me
here on youtube
are just my favorite people i love the
fact that i can just get on a live
stream and talk with you over and over
again
and just able to goof around with you
guys and i'm glad that you guys are
open to me promoting things in very
bizarre ways that seem
almost seem almost
antagonistic of me to do so but it's
only because i'm really passionate about
this project i really do
want you guys to give it a listen if you
haven't listened to it and you've been
listening to this
and you know it's one of those things
where it's like yeah i i would
absolutely love for you guys to
to uh to enjoy the podcast and i would
absolutely love for you guys to listen
to it
um but in all honesty like it's just
something that
i'm very proud of that we made and i
really do want you guys to
like enjoy it i would like it to be
successful more than anything i would
like you guys to actually
like the podcast so if you haven't
already definitely give it a try because
i think that we
have landed on a show that really
like it really encapsulates the best
elements of
bob wade and i's friendship because
we've been friends for a very long time
and you know every year that we've been
able to work together has been an
absolute joy
and the ability for me to be this is
like completely 100 honest here
like no no more bits no more jokes the
ability for me to make something with my
friends
is my favorite thing in the entire world
it's
it's always been something where i like
to split it with my friends and
share in the success but also just like
the fact that we get to do things
that we love and the fact that we get to
make things that we
thoroughly enjoy making and and if it
can at the end of it be
something that other people can enjoy as
well it's just the trifecta of
perfection that i love in terms of
creating things on youtube and and
bringing things to the internet you know
i'm out here in canada right now and i'm
filming
uh the edge of sleep the tv show um and
i just i literally started up this live
stream after i
i got done filming like 11 hours today
um but yeah i just i really do love
being able to do what i do
so just as final and i swear this will
be the last one i swear this will be the
last one
as a final uh word from me to you there
are links in the description
there are several links in the
description that will take you both to
apple podcast
take you to spotify it'll take you to
that website that you guys crashed i
think you actually did crash it
like is it still down i bet it's still
down i didn't i don't know what that
website is i i was just using it because
they suggested it
as a way to um get people to the
podcast a little easier but like in all
honesty like you guys keep breaking
everything
always and i don't know how you manage
to keep doing that but you always manage
to break websites whenever i send it to
you
and really like that means the world to
me i it's
very inconvenient but also i know it's
out of love
because you guys definitely do uh you do
support the things that i
ask you to support and that really does
honestly mean the world this is like
officially the bid is over
sorry the music was still going the bid
is over
the bit is over and it's just like one
of those things where
i am very happy to be able to do the
things that i i like to do and
i i know i know it's been 40 minutes
this is my gift my gift is being able to
for non-stop
um but this is not this is 100
honest thank you guys so much for
watching and thank you for so much for
letting me do the things that i
love to do the fact that i'm up here in
canada filming
a project that i never imagined that i
would be able to film because of a
podcast that i did
i didn't even write the podcast like i
just i just starred in it and i acted in
and now i'm acting it in the tv show
format
like that's that's nuts and it's all
because of you guys
believing it so strongly you guys
believed in the edge of sleep so
strongly
that it's being made into a tv show that
is
legitimately the reason that it's
happening it it
wouldn't have happened without you guys
and i want you guys to remember that
and recognize that and i i'm not saying
that distracted was gonna be a tv show
because
it's not that type of thing it's really
just something that we
enjoy doing and it's something that i
think you guys will enjoy listening to
but really like
thank you guys for supporting the
projects that i'm a part of and i
push you guys towards i would never
point you towards something that i don't
think that you would like
and if you don't like it that is also
fine but one last time
there's a link in the description below
there are several links go check out
distractable on apple podcast
and spotify or that third link that you
broke maybe it will repair sometimes but
it just links to apple podcast and
spotify
go search up distractible listen to our
first episode we're going to put out new
episodes
once a week and i think you'll enjoy it
a lot thank you everybody so much for
giving this a chance
and as always i'll see you
in the next video bye-bye bye
i'm actually gonna go guys bye
have a good night thank you